>>> AVENATTI IS A BEAST.
HE KEEPS POPPING TRUMP AND HIS
FOLKS IN THE MOUTH.
HE MAY BE THE SAVIOR OF THE
REPUBLIC.
>> HE IS A MASTER OF THE MEDIA
CYCLE.
>> I OWE AVENATTI AN APOLOGY.
FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS
I'M SAYING ENOUGH ALREADY,
MICHAEL.
I SEE YOU EVERY.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU HAVE TO SAY?
I WAS WRONG.
YOU HAVE A LOT TO SAY.
THE DEMOCRATS COULD LEARN
SOMETHING FROM YOU.
>> Tucker: SAVIOR OF THE ME
RUB -- SAVIOR OF THE RELUB --
REPUBLIC.
WHO GIVES THESE PEOPLE SHOWS.
HUNDREDS OF MEDIA APPEARANCES
PROPELLED HIM TO BE LEADING
CANDIDATE FOR THE PRESIDENCY.
BUT THE CREEPY PORN LAWYER
REMINDED THE PUBLIC WHILE
EVIDENCE AND THE PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE MATTER.
IT MAY HAVE SAVED BRETT
KAVANAUGH IN THE PROCESS.
SO NOW THE FORMER BENEFACTORS
ARE MAD AND THEY ARE TURNING
ON HIM.
>> SOME OF YOUR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES SAYING THE FELLOW
DEMOCRATS' CASE AGAINST
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH WAS WEAKENED
BY MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> AVENATTI IS THE BEST THING
TO HAPPEN TO KAVANAUGH.
ALL THE DEMOCRATS FLIRTING
WITH HIM HAVE TO BE
EMBARRASSED.
>> A LOT OF DEMOCRATS ARE
SAYING AND ARE YOU HEARING
THIS?
THAT HE TOOK A SYMPATHETIC
CASE WITH FORD AND TURNED IT
INTO A CIRCUS LOSING THEM THE
HIGH GROUND.
>> YES.
THE MICHAEL AVENATTI CIRCUS
COMES TO TOWN.
>> AVENATTI CAME IN WITH THE
SWETNICK ALLEGATION OF THE
DRUGGIE GANG RAPE STUFF THAT
SEEMS TO HAVE BEEN MUCH LESS
TAKEN AS CREDIBLE.
>> AVENATTI DUD A HUGE FAVOR
TO THE TRUMP WHITE HOUSE.
>> Tucker: DAVID IS AN
ATTORNEY AND FORMER ADVISER TO
SENATOR PATTY MURRAY.
HE JOINS US.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: DID IT TURN OUT
THAT STORMY DANIELS' FORMER
LAWYER NOT IN THE END THE
SAVIOR OF THE REPUBLIC AS
MSNBC DUBBED HIM?
>> IT GIVES HIM TOO MUCH
CREDIT TO SAY HE WAS THE
DECIDING FACTOR IN THIS.
WE KNOW JUSTICE KAVANAUGH WAS
CONFIRMED BECAUSE OF A PROCESS
THAT THE REPUBLICANS RAN AND
THEY WERE SINGLE-MIND AND
DETERMINED TO ENSURE THE
NOMINATION NO MATTER THE
SERIOUS AND CREDIBLE
ALLEGATIONS THAT WERE RAISED
AGAINST HIM.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT.
I'M NOT SURE HE WAS DECISIVE
IN THIS.
THEY WEREN'T THE ONLY
SINGLE-MINDED DETERMINED
PARTY.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE THOSE
THINGS TOO.
WOULD YOU DESCRIBE THE
ALLEGATION OF HIS CLIENT THAT
SHE ATTENDED TEN CONSECUTIVE
GANG RAPES, DIDN'T REPORT IT
TO THE POLICE OR TELL FRIENDS
OR RELATIVES AND JUDGE
KAVANAUGH WAS PRESENT AT SOME
OF THESE DRUGGING THE PUNCH.
BUT WAIT, SHE SAYS LATER HE
WASN'T.
IS THAT A CREDIBLE ALLEGATION,
DO YOU THINK?
>> WHAT STRIKES ME ABOUT THE
ALLEGATION AND I BELIEVE SHE
SWORE UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY
IN HER DECLARATION.
AS A LAWYER THAT SAYS
SOMETHING TO ME.
>> Tucker: SHE CONTRADICTED
IT IN A LATER INTERVIEW.
>> MY TAKE-AWAY, OCTOBER 2
THAT SHE WANTED THAT
ALLEGATION TO BE INCLUDED THE
SCOPE OF THE F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION.
TO ME THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A
RIGHT WAY FORWARD ALLOWING FOR
THE F.B.I. TO FAIRLY AND
IMPARTIALLY CREDIT HER
ALLEGATION.
>> HOW WOULD THEY DO THAT
SINCE E GAVE HER DECLARATION
UNDER OATH.
SHE NAMED NO OTHER PERSON
PRESENT OTHER THAN PEOPLE WHO
ALREADY UNDER OAT DENIED --
UNDER OATH DENIED SHE WAS
TELLING THE TRUTH.
THERE WAS NOBODY LEFT TO
INTERVIEW BUT HER AND SHE WAS
MAKING CLAIMS SO STUPID EVEN
SENATORS DIDN'T BELIEVE IT.
THERE WERE NOT TEN GOING RAPES
IN A ROW AND NOBODY KNEW IT.
WHY DIDN'T THEY SAY C'MON,
THIS IS NOT HELPFUL.
>> I THINK YOU DID SEE MEMBERS
GIVE MORE CREDENCE TO
DR. CHRSTINE BLASEY FORD'S
TESTIMONY.
THE FOCUS ON FORD'S TESTIMONY
WAS POEERFUL BECAUSE SHE
FORWARD AND TESTIFIED AND THEY
COULD ASK HER QUESTIONS.
THE BROADER TAKE-AWAY FOR ME
IS UNFORTUNATELY THE F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION WAS NOT
COMPREHENSIVE.
IN FACT, JUSTICE KAVANAUGH AND
DR. CHRSTINE BLASEY FORD
WEREN'T EVEN INTERVIEWED AS
PART OF THE INVESTIGATION.
SO, I THINK IT WAS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY FOR TO US CLEAR UP
A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING.
ARE YOU SAYING BECAUSE CREEPY
PORN LAWYER'S CLIENT CLAIMED
TEN CONSECUTIVE GANG RAPES
THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN AND YOU
KNOW IT AS WELL AS I, THAT SHE
WASN'T INTERVIEWED FROM THE
F.B.I. MEANS HE COULDN'T HAVE
BEEN CONFIRMED.
>> I WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU ARE
MR. AVENATTI USING THAT TERM.
I DON'T WATCH YOUR SHOW.
>> I'M NOT FULLY -- RIGHT.
THE LAWYER WHO REPRESENTED
STORMY DANIELS, SAVIOR OF THE
REPUBLIC.
>> I'M NOT SURE HE IS A
LEADING CANDIDATE.
>> Tucker: HE HAS BEEN
INVITED BY DEMOCRATS IN EARLY
PRIMARY STATES.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT BECAUSE
HIS CLIENT, THE TEN GANG RAPE
IN A ROW CLIENT, SHE WASN'T
INTERVIEWED ABOUT HER LIED
CROSS CLAIMS THAT SOMEHOW
KAVANAUGH SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
CONFIRMED?
>> THAT IS NOT WHAT I SAID.
I WISH SHE HAD BEEN INTERVIEW
AND THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
LOOKED AT THE STORY AND
OFFERED A COMPLETE RECORD.
I'M SAYING I THINK WE HAVE A
MISSED OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE
THERE ARE SERIOUS QUESTIONS
OUTSTANDING BECAUSE THE F.B.I.
INVESTIGATION WAS NOT ALLOWED
TO BE AS COMPLETE AND HOLISTIC
AS I THINK MANY MEMBERS,
CERTAINLY THE DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS, YOU SAW THE STATEMENT
WISH THEY HAD BEEN.
>> Tucker: QUICKLY BOTTOM
LINE IT.
JUST ABOUT THE CREEPY PORN
LAWYER, C.P.L. COMPONENT.
ARE YOU HAPPY TO HAVE HIM IN
THE PARTY AND KEEP DOING WHAT
HE IS DOING?
THAT IS WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
STAND FOR OR GO BACK TO DOING
WHATEVER HE DOES.
>> WE ARE A BIG TENT PARTY SO
I AM HAPPY FOR ANYONE STEPPING
UP FOR WHAT THEY BELIEVE IN
BUT IT WILL BE A BIG CROWD
FIELD SO I'M NOT GOING TO
OFFER A FORECAST WHO IS THE
NOMINEE.
>> Tucker: I AM ROOTING FOR
HIM.
I'M NOT A DEMOCRAT BUT I AM